well the rescue operations here in the
city of adiaman are still continuing
however the full the hope is almost gone
in the city right here you can see that
we are just in front of rubble a
collapsed building and over there has
written it's controlled it's checked so
that means that rescue teams have
checked this building and there is no
one alive there there's no hope and now
that's why they just moved forward move
to another collapse building hopefully
to find someone that is still alive I
have recently been in this city as well
and indeed I grew up in this city and I
have worked in many of the streets of
this city and now uh coming to cover the
earthquake here is quite a little bit
emotional for me as well it's my
hometown and seeing that many of the
streets that I have worked with my
friends are now leveled down and many of
the people the faces that I knew in this
city are now gone forever however that
the tragedy is still unfolding here and
the rescue Force are still ongoing
they're trying to find some voices to
hear some voices but as I said the hopes
are almost gone here the buildings are
heavily damaged here and definitely the
sense of normality is almost completely
lost